like if I rated myself one to ten I give  myself a five I think I'm normal looking  and I just think it's based on my  results I think if I was in eight nine  or ten I would have had modeling  contracts because people in the top 20  of beauty they get they get modeling  contracts what is beauty so what what is  beauty I mean there's a lot of things  like if you  I mean you can you can go online and  have people rate your pictures and they  rank you one to ten that's wild and and  so you can get you can get a lot of data  that says how attractive you are in  society and men will wait you women will  rate you like every day  how we look is like how we represent  ourselves it's not fun but it's just  like being honest